director James Toback reportedly accused  of sexual harassment according to a  story in the Los Angeles Times on Sunday  the 72 year old director is facing  accusations from more than 30 women who  have come forward alleging misconduct  Toback is known for his films that two  girls and a guy and black and white and  he was nominated for an Oscar in 1992  her Best Original Screenplay on Warren  Beatty's flick Bugsy he allegedly used  these credits to his advantage with  women the LA Times claims the filmmaker  would quote drop names if the women he  was approaching did not believe him  tobik denied the allegations when  contacted by The Times saying he had  never met any of the women making these  claims or if he had it was quote for  five minutes and he has quote no  recollection the reports of tow backs  alleged sexual harassment come in the  wake of similar allegations toward movie  exec Carvey Weinstein Weinstein has  denied any non-consensual sex